I became a journalist because i am
broadly interested in almost everything
but not deeply interested and so I
wanted to learn about just about
everything but but then I wanted to move
on a DD of the mind and so the
combination of my natural proclivity
towards that type of breadth of learning
and the ability to do it anywhere and to
do my craft anywhere with new media and
with technology it's like crack really
it's it's terribly addictive that said I
do produce I cope reduce and co-host a
web show called TMI weekly in
conjunction with next new networks which
does the Obama girl amongst many other
things the founders of MTV and the
founders of Nickelodeon started this
company and they want to become the
Viacom of the web and that show is based
in New York so I am tethered here we do
tape every Tuesday but other than that I
am free to roam and although I do write
my column for Time Out New York I can be
anywhere and I have been anywhere I've
written it on my laptop sitting on the
beaches of st. Lucia before by the way
wouldn't recommend it you should really
be focusing on the ocean but it is what
it's allowed me to do is really offer my
readers a true glimpse into my daily
life and what that does is it breaks
down the fourth wall which can be very
dangerous it breaks down this fourth
wall between me and my readers which is
not something that prior to this new
technology was possible in journalism
you might have a columnist and people
read them for years I mean I grew up
reading the Chicago Tribune and the same
column is still there I mean it's like
the same people and you know you feel
like you know them a little bit this is
taking it to a whole new level and that
feeling is something I also saw with
Oprah people believe
genuinely whether they know it or not
although I do believe that they're
conscious of it with Oprah that she is
their friend but she's not and that's
what I'm establishing with my life cast
as i call it because i hate the word
blog and i don't think it's indicative
of what i do and sometimes it can be a
name the way that looking at a
stranger's family vacation photos is not
fun sometimes i could understand if you
know it's stranger if they don't know me
but i have a lot of readers who feel
like they're my friends